foreign
on the idea which perhaps I stated last
time we spoke and perhaps not but I
certainly believe that our state of mind
and body at any point in time is
strongly dictated by our state of mind
and body
in the hours and days prior to that and
on the one hand people are going to hear
that and say well duh if you're sleep
deprived you're going to feel like
garbage and if you're well rested you'll
feel great
that's kind of the top Contour of it but
when one looks at the Neuroscience for
instance of sleep
you start to realize that you know the
amount of rapid eye movement sleep that
you're going to get in any 90-minute
bout of sleep because your sleep is
broken up into these 90 minute segments
more or less
is strongly dictated by
the ratio of slow wave sleep AKA deep
sleep and rapid eye movement sleep that
you had in the previous 90 minute bout
and then when you start to look at the
research in terms of waking States you
start to find that your ability to be
focused say for about to work in the
morning or the afternoon or a creative
brainstorm session or I don't know to
maybe drill into some personal issue
that you're dealing with during therapy
or just on a walk or while journaling
is not a square wave function you know
none of us should sit down and expect
ourselves to just drop into that state
much of our ability to move into that
state effectively whatever effective
means right whatever the target
or goal of that
as I'm calling it is is going to be
dictated by what happened in the
previous
moments and hours
and so
when I zoom out from that what I've
doubled down on is this idea that
they're just a core set of foundational
things that we have to re-up every 24
hours you know I think thanks to the
incredibly hard work of Dr Matt Walker
at Berkeley right the Sleep Diplomat on
Twitter right it's such a great name
because it's so appropriate I mean a
decade ago or so you know it was like
I'll sleep when I'm dead that was the
dominant mentality out there and yeah
sleep's great but you know getting stuff
done is more important I mean Matt has
really impressed on everybody that our
mental health our physical health and
our ability to perform is so strongly
dependent on our ability to get quality
sleep maybe not every night of our life
right I mean we have to be realistic but
that sleep is vital so a hat tip is
insufficient
so sleep is critical but sleep is just
one of about I would say five things
that really set the the buoyancy or the
foundation upon which our nervous system
is able to accomplish these transitions
that I'm talking about at all and
those five things are sleep right in the
absence of quality sleep over two or
three days you're just gonna fall to
pieces in the presence of quality
sufficient sleepover
two or three days You're Gonna function
in an amazing level
there's a gain of function and a loss of
function there it's not just if you
sleep poorly you function less well you
sleep better you function much better so
sleep I would say is at the top of the
list
nutrients
you know and there are you can think
macronutrients and so you carnivores are
only eating meat and your vegans are
only eating plants and you're
you're omnivores which is I think
probably 90 of the world is eating a
combination of those but you know
quality
nutrients I think that when I look at
all of the nutrition literature and
arguments out there it seems that
everyone can agree on one thing which is
that probably 80 percent or more of our
nutrition should come from unprocessed
or minimally processed sources minimally
processed would require some cooking but
could survive on the Shelf as opposed to
packaged Foods or highly palatable Foods
so you've got sleep nutrients but then
we should also put in micronutrients and
this is where maybe we'll get into a
discussion about supplementation I think
that there's
supplementation or supplements is a bit
of a misnomer because it implies vitamin
supplements and people say well can't
you get all that from food or that whey
protein isn't that just food wouldn't
you be better off with a chicken breast
okay well then when you talk about
convenience and you know absorption okay
but then there's this huge category of
things
ranging from the kind of esoterically
named things like ashwagandha and
shilaji and tongali and fidojia
aggressive that's right I mean exactly
all the herbal stuff right you're not
going to get that from food yeah so
should we call them supplements at all
yeah so let's just say the second thing
is nutrients and that includes
macronutrients and that includes
micronutrients as well so those two
things then the third would be movement
right and this has also been an enormous
transition in the last I think just five
years which is not just for people
interested in bodybuilding or power
lifting or for competitive athletes but
now it seems everybody including the
elderly understand that you need a
combination of cardiovascular exercise
and you need resistance training whether
or not it's with body weight or weights
or machines Etc that you need both I
mean not a week goes by without seeing
an article in one of the major
Publications out there standard media
what's called traditional media will be
nice to them traditional media that
highlight some study showing that you
know resistance training in elderly
people can offset Alzheimer's or you
know or that as our friend Peter attia
has pointed out so many times that many
of the end of life creating injuries are
due to people older people stepping down
The Eccentric movements okay so so you
need movement that's the third category
fourth I will argue and I like to think
that maybe I've helped this movement if
you want to call it that is light in
particular sunlight in the early part
and throughout the middle of the day
and trying to minimize the amount of
artificial light that you're exposed to
in the evening and late night hours most
of the time because you have to live
life just fundamental and then the last
category that's important is social
connection AKA relationships let's just
call it relationships because that can
include relationship to self so those
things set up the core foundation and I
think one way to think about them is
just as a list another is to think about
them in terms of a of a schedule basis
and that's how I've really doubled down
is I realize that every 24 hours I need
to invest something into each one of
those things so I think that you know 10
years ago or five years ago or even two
years ago I used to think okay like
what's the workout split or how am I
going to eat for the next couple of
months you know what am I trying to
optimize for is it muscle is it fat loss
is it just maintaining is it energy is
it Focus that's all fine and good but
sleep nutrients exercise light
relationships those really establish the
foundation of what I consider to be all
of the elements that create our ability
to move
as seamlessly as possible between the
states that we happen to be in and the
states we desire to be in and when I
zoom out and I think about what are the
major struggles that I and it seems most
everyone deals with it's like how to get
more focused okay so we can talk about
you know what do you take what's the
supplement you know but you have to say
well how are you sleeping have you done
any exercise you really always find
yourself or I find myself taking 10
steps back and then moving through the
sequence of five things before you can
even begin to talk about whether or not
taking three or six hundred milligrams
of alpha GPC and how often to do that
and does it work and yes it works Etc
but those things really set the
foundation and so I like to think of
those five things every single day you
have to re-up on sleep every 24 hours or
try to re-up on movement every 24 hours
you can go a day or so immobile but you
better move the next day right and
ideally you're moving seven days a week
doesn't necessarily mean trained to
failure and running marathon seven days
a week you can goggens your life or you
can not go against your life
for those who don't know I'm referring
to David Goggins there by the way food
seems to never stop moving although I
just learned meditates two hours every
night every night and I'm inclined to
believe when he says that that indeed
does that
you need nutrients even if they come
from stored sources even if you're gonna
fast you're gonna fast for a day or two
okay fine I've done that I know you've
done that easy I would put hydration
under nutrients too so you can derive
nutrients from stored
fat protein Etc glycogen light you're
gonna need that every 24 hours
you're going to need sunlight even if
through cloud cover
and you're going to want to avoid right
artificial lights at night not every
night but most nights of your life and
then that relationships one is the one
that maybe we can go into in a little
bit more depth at some point but
it requires focus it requires attention
every 24 hours
now that doesn't necessarily mean you
have to see friends talk to friends text
friends every 24 hours some people are
far more introverted than others but
then you're working on your relationship
to yourself
in that solo time and hopefully when
you're spending time with others as well
that has some internal repercussions so
if I've doubled down on anything it's
the understanding that there is no
so-called optimization there is no real
interest at least from me in trying to
layer in other things unless I'm paying
attention to each and every one of those
things every 24 hours you have to re-up
on each and every one of those five
things every 24 hours and if you don't
you can get by for a day or two
but pretty soon you're going to hit that
wall where you won't be able to do any
of the things that most people are
actually seeking to do and the last
thing I'll say about that is you know I
think people hear a list of those five
things they think gosh okay well that
must be nice for you Andrew and Tim you
know you wake up you look at sunlight
you guys don't have kids you know like
you don't have to worry about kids
running around you don't have to
you know you can exercise there are ways
of layering in the protocols that re-up
as I'm referring to it these five things
every 24 hours that also include other
people in your life
kids pets Etc
exercise certainly can include that as
well but I would argue that there is no
showing up properly
for yourself and for the other people in
your life unless these things are being
handled and it's not about becoming soft
and cushy it's about becoming quite
resilient and effective and I think this
for me is the
it seems so simple
but
as our friend Paul Conte said to me
recently he said you know after all the
analysis and pouring through things in
the complicated Notions of the
subconscious he's a psychiatrist after
all you know in the end really great
mental health is about simple practices
like first principles of self-care so to
which I raised my hand and said well
like what is a first principle of
self-care I'm a biologist after all and
he said aha it's basically the things
that we were just talking about
there's those five things and so I I'm
doubling down I'm tripling down on those
as essential
to the point where nothing else really
happens for very long unless those five
things are tended to